Evet Babamın işi Dolayısıyla hayatımın
ilk 15 yılında iki ülke 3 şehir 10 tane
de ev değiştirdik sürekli bir taşınma
havasında yaydık Hatta hala Annem ve kız
kardeşim taşın Masalar bile bir buçuk
iki yılda bir evdeki eşyaların yerlerini
değiştirirler bunun Ben de şöyle bir
etkisi oldu Çok uzun süre kendimi bir
yere aitse demedim orta ikide spor
yapmaya başladım kendime ait
hissettiğini ihtiyaç spor oldu top
oynuyordum çok şanslıydım ki çok iyi
antrenörlerin ve çok sevdiğim takım
arkadaşlarım var takım sporlarının şöyle
bir faydası var Özellikle küçük çocuklar
için mücadele ettikten sonra kazansanız
da kaybettiğinizde tebrik etmeyi
öğreniyorsunuz Eğer bir takım
arkadaşınız kötü oynuyorsa onu motive
edici cesaretlendirme ye başlıyor
bu oyunu kurallarına göre oynuyorsunuz
azimle maç bitene kadar oyun bitene
kadar bütün gücünüzü oraya veriyorsunuz
bu esasında sadece duygusal zekası
yüksek ve empati yüksek insanların
yapabileceği bir şey ve takım sporları
da bir çocuk için bunu en hızlı
geliştirebileceği bu değerleri e hızlı
benim isteyebileceği şeylerden bir
tanesi Tabii bireysel takımlarda değer
koşul çok iyi ise bu da sizin
gelişimimizi sağlayacak şeylerden bir
tanesi olabilir empatinin önemi şu
Hepimiz sosyal ilişki ağlarının
içerisindeyiz bu ağların içinde bu
ilişkilerin içerisinde birisine
derdimizi anlatabilmek dertleştiği miz
kişinin derdini gerçekten anlayabilmek
ve benim silebilmek derdi sadece
anlamakta kalmak değil o derdin çözümü
için girişimde bulunabilmek için
duygusal zekamızın yüksek ve empati
mizin de yüksek olması gerekiyor Bunun
olmadığı durumlarda bir felaket yoluna
giriyoruz ayrımcılığın başladığı öteki
O benim başladı Hatta ırkçılığa kadar
giden O kötü Yolun Başı hep duygusal
zekanın düşük olduğu ülkelerde başlıyor
Bunu sadece sosyal ilişkilerin içinde
düşünmeyelim esasında içinde yaşadığımız
dünyanın da bu empatiye bu duygusal
zekayı ihtiyacı var hepimiz içinde
yaşadığımız dünyanın kaynaklarını
kullanıyoruz ve karşında hiçbir şey
vermiyoruz sadece dünya değil bu dünyayı
paylaştığımız hayvanlar canlılar ve
bitkilerle de aynı ilişki kurmamız
gerekiyor ki bu etkileşim ve bu iletişim
Karşılıklı olsun sadece aldığımız değil
bazen de verdiğimiz ve hatta bazen
dünyanın hayvanların canlıların ve diğer
bütün insanların sorunlarını çözebilme
çalıştığımız bir ilişki ağına sahip
olabilir Türklerin hayırsever olduğu
öğretti bize çocukluğumuzdan beri fakat
veriler ve anketler bize Bunun doğru
olmadığını söylüyor bu belli
ve Ortalama bir Türk gelirinin on binde
beşini dernek ve vakıflara bağış yapıyor
kendi geldiğimizden bir hesap
yapabilirsiniz verdiklerini söyledikleri
kıyafetler yemek Cami yardımı ve
dilencilere verdikleri paralarla da bu
yüzden bire ancak yaklaşıyor Ortalama
bir Amerikalı ne kadar bağış yaptı
biliyor musunuz dernek ve vakıflara
gelirinin yüzde iki buçuk
bu Müslümanlıkta şart olan zekat oranı
bilen var mı
bu doğru kırkta bir ufak bir matematik
hesabıyla bunu yüzde iki buçuk eşit
olduğunu görüyoruz esasında Ortalama bir
Amerikalı Bu şartlarda ortalama
müslümandan daha Müslüman Şimdi bunu
değiştirmek için yapabileceğimiz en
önemli şeylerden bir tanesi gönüllülük
gönüllülük ve bağışıklığı şöyle bir
önemi var Eğer empati mi yüksek değilse
eğer karşı tarafın derdini anlamaya
çalışmıyor Sak bu kişiye Biz ne
zamanımız yeriz ve paramızı veririz
gönüllü de böyle gözünüzde çok
büyütmeyin bazen ufacık işler yaparak
böyle kocaman işler yapmanız bütün
dünyayı değiştirmemiz gerekiyor bazen
azıcık bir zamanınız ayırarak bir sürü
insanın hayatını değiştirebilir size
küçük bir örnek vermek istiyorum Her
izlediğimde çok duygulandım ve çok
etkilendiğim reklamlardan bir tane
etrafında işitme engelli Muharrem'e
yapılan bir sürpriz
Bu Muharrem
ve işitme engelli ve işaret diliyle
konuşuyor rfa kat işaret dili
anlaşabildiği insan sayısı sınırlı
Ne ablası ve 3-4 arkadaşı dışında
iletişim kurabildiği kimse yok bu
sürpriz hazırlamak için bir ay boyunca
uğraşıyorlar Bir ay boyunca Muharrem'in
her sabah evden çıktıktan sonra yolda
karşılaştığı kişiler girdi fırın bindiği
taksiciye sadece iki üç kelime işaret
dili öğretiyor öyle büyük bir sohbettir
iki üç kelime işaret dili öğretiyorlar
Muharrem bu sabah evinden çıkıyor
ablasıyla beraber yolda çarpıştığı
kişiden fırına girdiğinde konuştu
fırıncı taksiye bindiğinde Taksim'de onu
ettiği iki üç kelimeye kadar işaret
diliyle konuştuğunu görünce Muharrem'i
yüzündeki şaşkınlığa inanamazsınız Eğer
bu reklamı seyret etmediyseniz gidince
bir hepsini Seyr etmenizi tavsiye edilir
bir gün böyle bir konuşmadan sonra şans
eseri Bu reklamı yapan Ajansı başkanı
ile karşılaştım dedim ki Muharrem hiç mi
anlamadım bu reklamı çekildiğini ajansın
sahibi güldü dedi ki aynı şeyi Biz de
merak ettik ve sorduk Muharrem'i
cevabını biliyor musunuz mu
İyi ki bir şeylerin garip gittiğinin
farkına vardım Ama bu hayatın boyunca
hayal ettiğim rüya gibiydi Gözlerimi
kapatıp sürekli dünyadaki herkesin
işaret dilde konuştuğunu düşünürdüm O
yüzden o günde gözlerini kapadı ve bu
rüyanın hiç bitmemesini çalıştı sadece
bir günaydınla Türkiye'deki 3000000
işitme engellinin hayatını
değiştirebilirsiniz yapacağınız Sadece
bu Günaydın böyle söylüyoruz şimdi
gönüllülükle hayırseverlik
karşımızdakini anlamak onun hayatını
değiştirmek esasında bize
heyecanlandıran bir iş için
karşımızdakini de güzel bir iletişim
kurmakla başlıyor size anlatmak
istediğim bir hikaye Bu benim oğlum İsko
Yaklaşık 3 ay önce karşı taraf annemi
ziyaretten bu tarafa geri dönüyoruz daha
önce is quite göstermedim bina gösterdi
Visco Bak burası benim yedi yıl boyunca
çalıştığım işyeri her sabah buraya
gittim geldi daha hiç görmediği için
şaşırdı dedi ki ne iş
bu burası holdinglerin Holding ne demek
dedi dedim patronu çok parası var Ben
enerji yatırımı yapıyor Otel alıyor
şirketler alıyor satıyor şöyle baktı
bana neden dedi dedim parası çok daha
fazla para kazanmak için yapıyor neden
dedi
ve o soruya bir cevap veremedim bakın
hepimiz şu anda dünyada neden amacı ne
ve Amacım ne diyecek çocukların hızlı
büyüdü bir dünyadayız çocukların bundan
sonra çok büyük bir çoğunluğu amacının
ne olduğunu bilmediği kendi amacının ne
olduğunu bilmediği bir durumda
şirketlerde çalışmayacak şu anda daha
Türkiye'de olmasa bile Avrupa'da ve
batıda mülakatlarda Son soruyu gençler
soruyor sordukları soru bu şirketin
amacını artık patronların hiçbirisi
benim tek sosyal fayda istihdam yaratmak
deyip bu çocukları kaldıramayacak lar
Çünkü şirketlerin artık bir amacın
olması şirketlerin artık çevreye veya
sosyal hayattaki bir sorunu çözmek için
kurulması gerekiyor Biz bu şirketlere
sosyal girişim diyoruz bu böyle çok
uzakta bir kavram değil 15-20 yıldır
dünyada yavaş yavaş büyüyen Türkiye'de
yeni yeni duyulmaya
bu kavram esasında sosyal girişimlerin
kurucularının çoğunu hikayesi günlükle
başlıyor çoğunu hikayesi bir sorunla
başlıyor bu sorunu çözmek için bir
şirket kuruyorlar bir girişim kuruyorlar
ve bu girişimde Sürdürülebilir bir
şekilde o sorunu o sıkıntıyı çözsün diye
bu bir şirket haline geliyor bu şirketin
kuruluş amacı para değil bu şirketin
kuruluş amacı bir sorunu çözmek Size
birkaç örnek vereyim vikipedi'ye
bilirsiniz vikipedi'nin kursu Jimmy ve
yok şimdi beyaz 35 yaşına kadar yatırım
bankacılığı yapıyor yatırım bankalarında
araştırma raporları yazarak opsiyon
satanlara araştırma sağlıyor 35 yaşında
bir şeylerin eksik olduğunu farkına
varıyor onun en büyük sıkıntısı doğru
bilgiye istediği zamanda erişemiyor
olması öyle bir platform kuruyor ki
dünyadaki insanların istediği her zaman
bazen kısıtlamaları olsa da istediği her
zaman istediği anda en doğru bilgiyi
ulaşabilmesini sağlıyor
o gün örnek vereyim Bego bu üstünde şu
an giydiğim ve gojin sahibi Bego 15
yaşında İstanbul'a geliyor 15 yaşında
İstanbul'a geldiğinde geride ondan para
bekleyen bir aile ve 8 tane kardeşi var
İstanbul'da konut sektörüne giriyor ve
kot kumlama da çalışmaya başlıyor ot
kullanma bildiğiniz Hani beyazlatılmış
kodlardan bahsediyordu egonun sağlığı
buna beş sene veriyor beş sene sonra
Bego silikozis hastalığı yüzünden
akciğerlerinin yüzde 40'ını kaybediyor
siliko Siz kısaca şu demek ciğerlerin
içinde çimento atıldığını düşünün
içerideki nem yüzünden Bunlar donuyor ve
ciğer denizin bir kısmı beton haline
geliyor ve Go şahıslardan akciğerlerin
sağ yüzde 40'ı gidiyor beş sene sonra
120 tane arkadaşının gözünün önünde
öldüğünü görüyor Ve Go isyan etmiyor
İstanbul'a geldiğinde az Türkçe bilen
Bego Türkçeyi daha seri bir şekilde
konuşma
de İngilizce öğreniyor bilgisayar
öğreniyor ve Türkiye'de kot kumlama sını
yasaklanacak kampanya başlatıyor bununla
da yetinmiyor dünyada kot kullanması
bitmesi sağlayacak kampanyalarında
başında duruyor kod kullanmadan sonra
bir bakıyor Başka bir metot kullanmaya
başlıyorlar ve bu oturuyor düşünüyor
diyor ki ben bunu da durdursam başka
metot gelecek bunu durdursam başka Mesut
kullanacak o zaman diyor benim dünyaya
temiz giysi hareketinin ne olduğunu
anlatmam gerekiyor diyor ve kendisi
oturuyor bu kutu üretiyor bu kutu
üretirken tamamen doğaya Saygılı
insanlara saygılı kimseye ve çevreye
zarar vermeyecek bir şekilde bu kutu
üretiyor bakım egonun amacı para
kazanmak değil ve bugüne kadar Bu kottan
yüz tane saat ve egonun amacı dünyadaki
temiz giysi hareketini başlatmak ve
şimdiden bazı markalar da egoyla oturup
onların üretim sistemlerine
katılabileceğini anlamak için
bu başladılar Mesut e-bursluluk kurucusu
Mesut Van'daki depremden sonra
İstanbul'a gelir üniversiteyi kazanıyor
burs bulamıyor Bir buçuk sene onlarca
burs programına başvuruyor fakat buz
alamadığı için istediği Okula gidemiyor
İki sene sonra yurtdışına gitmek için
burs buluyor Londra'da üniversiteyi
bitiriyor Türkiye geliyor herkes gibi iş
bulmak için bir yerlere başvurmuyor şunu
anlıyor bir bursun bir gencin hayatında
ne kadar önemli olduğunu 22 23 yaşında
e-bursum diye platform kuruyor şuanda 25
26 yaşında olan Mesut 10 sene önce burs
bulamayan Mesut şu anda 10 bini Aşkın
gence bu sağlamış durumda Ben şu anda
ana amacı spor olan yani İstanbul'u daha
sağlıklı ve daha fazla spor yapmayı amaç
edinmiş bir şirkette çalışıyorum ve bu
şirketteki görevim bana teklif
edilmesini tek sebebi 12 yıl boyunca
yaptığım gönüllülük
o ilk defa 14 yıl önce İstanbul Maratonu
koştum bitirmek inanılmaz birisi o uzun
süre antreman yapıp o koşu bitirmek
muhteşem Biz fakat ikinci sene
hazırlanırken bir şey Beni huzursuz
etmeye başladı aynı antremanı yapıyorum
Sabahları biraz daha zor kalkıyorum bir
şekilde zorlanıyor dedim ki bu böyle
olmayacak Bu koşu sadece kendim için
değil başka bildirdi içinde yapmam
gerekiyor ve bu koşum omurilik saçlarını
alalım bir anda ne oldu biliyor musunuz
o Sabahları zor kalkmam yataktan
toplayarak ya zıplayarak kalkma dönüştü
beni zorlayan antrenmanlar benim için
daha keyifli bir hale geldi ve o Koşun
sonunda 8 tane omurilik felçlisi nin
yürüyemeyen Hatta evinden çıkamıyor
omurilik felçlisi nin hayatı ve aramıza
katılmasına vesile oldu adımlar Bütün
bunlar esasında insanın yaptığı işe bir
anlam katması Bütün bunlar insanı
yaptıklarıyla başkalarının sorunlarını
çözmesi bugün Geldiğimiz noktada a
bu kişilik 12 sene önce kurmuş adım adım
şu anda 91 kişiye ulaştı 90 bin kişi
koşullarıyla
36 100 bin kişinin bağış yapıp 230 bin
kişinin 230.000 canlının hayatını
değişmesine vesile oldu olur Bazen
sayılar çok şey ifade etmeyebilir Bakın
230b şu anlama geliyor demin gördüğümüz
yer çankırı'yı Çankırı Türkiye'nin 62
büyük ili Çankırı'da 230 bin kişi
yaşıyor hedefimiz bütün haritanı
kıpkırmızı olması bütün Türkiye'nin bir
şekilde Öyle ya da böyle iyilik peşinde
koşmaya başlamaz size daha önce
anlatmadığın bir hikaye da anlatmak
istiyorum Bu dayımla ilgili dedemin işi
vesilesiyle Dedem idareci Kaymakamlık
yapıyor Bütün Türkiye'de farklı
ilçelerde Kaymakamlık yapıyor dayım
sekiz dokuz yaşındayken Posof dolar
Posof o zaman karşısında için şimdi
Ardahan daima bir çift bot alıyorlar
okula yürüyerek gidip geliyor Tuncer
okula gidip gelirken
bu soğukta o karda ayakları sıcacık
kalsın hastalanması diye Tunceli bir
çift ayakkabı alıyorlar 3-4 gün sonra
anneannem kapıyı bir açıyı bakıyor
Tuncay'ın ayakları çıplak oğlum
ayakkabıların nerede diyor yolda
gelirken ayakkabısı olmayan bir
arkadaşımı gördüm Ayakkabılarımı ona
verdim diyor Türkiye'nin de dayısı olan
dayım Tuncer o gün ayakkabılarını
ayakkabısı olmayan bir çocuğa veriyor Bu
hikaye esasında Bunu farklı bir sene
önce vardım bu iki ay benim üzerinde
inanılmaz büyük oluşturdu Durmadan bana
anlatan bu hikaye ağırlığı Hisset sebebi
şuydu ne gençliğimde ne Çocukluğumda
ayakkabıların çıkıp hiç birisine
vermemişti fakat adım adım sayesinde
ayakkabılarını çıkarıp Vermedim ama bu
ayakkabılar ve 90 bin kişinin daha bu
ayakkabıları sayesinde 230 bin kişinin
hayatını değişmesiyle ben artık bu
hikaye ağırlığında bu iken yükünden
kendini Kurtulmuş hissediyorum çünkü
dünyaya
oy vermem gereken borcunun bir kısmını
geriye verdiğini düşünüyoruz Bu dünyaya
geldiğimizde esasında sürekli olarak bu
dünyanın kaynaklarını kullanıyoruz
çalıyoruz ödünç alıyoruz ve karşımda
Geriye hiçbir şey vermiyoruz
yapabileceğimiz en önemli şeylerden bir
tanesi gönüllük tür gönüllülük bu çok
sevdiğim bir cümle gönüllülük bu dünyada
Ödediğimiz O da kiralıktır bu dünyaya
geri verebileceğiniz tek şey gönüllülük
bu dünyaya kiramızı vermezsek ne olur
kiramızı vermediğiniz zaman elektriğimiz
kesilir suyumuz kesilir Elimizi
kaybederiz dünyanın başına bir şey
gelecek diye çok üzülmeye Gerek yok Biz
birbirimizi yiyip biz bu dünyada bir
şeyleri değiştirmediğiniz zaman yavaş
yavaş hepimiz yok olacağız dünya burada
kalacak 200-300 yıl sonra bu sular
tekrar tertemiz olacak bu ağaçlar tekrar
yemyeşil olacak
Bu Dünya yeni Kiracıları beklemeye
başlayacak ta ki ahlaklı birbiriyle
düzgün ilişki kuran dünyadaki canlılara
ve dünyaya saygı duyan yeni Kiracıları
gelene kadar sizlerden istediğim tek şey
sizi heyecanlandıran o sorunu çözdüğümüz
zaman sizi yataktan daha iyi kaldıran
amacı bulmamız Kimimiz bunu 89 yaşında
buluyor Kimimiz bunu 88 yaşında buluyor
ama en kötüsü bunu hiç bulamadan ölüp
gitmek borçlu bir şekilde ölüp gitmek
yapabileceğimiz tek şey bu dünyadaki
kiramızı ödemek Çok teşekkür ederiz